and here come the yankees they are led
by their ace
garrett cole
who will be pitching against the red sox
and yankee stadium as a as a yankee for
the first time two down and here is jd
martinez
2-2
swing and a mist this is a kid uh colton
brewer who is starting he's an opener
they're gonna go to their bullpen there
are 13 guys in there well here's mike
talkman
there's the pitch tachman
can't hold up on the swing it's in there
anyway strike three a little cutter over
the inside corner
there's the number nine hitter
jonathan arrows
goes there's a strike throw the second
it's a beauty they got him what a throw
by sanchez to erase pilar it's as good
as it gets right there from any catcher
and the payoff is grounded to the
infield the mayhew
a little flip to first you end the
inning no runs one hit but no one left
with the caught stealing at the end of
two and a half
no score
but here's gleber
who had an infield single his first time
a diving stop by arrow
now in his line to right field pilar is
going to play it off the base of the
wall
boyd scores right behind him as hicks
he'll score it's a two-run double for
torres and the yankees lead two-nothing
the new pitcher is the right-hander
austin bryce
and he faces gary sanchez
the pause the pitch from austin bryce a
ground ball up the middle played by
aruuz the second baseman but he's on the
shortstop side of the bag
he throws him out now here's the top of
the order alex
verdugo high fly ball that one driven
deep to right field back into the corner
and that ball makes the second deck
alex verdugo with the blast and the red
sox get on the board against cole
gardner's at second with a stolen base
and here is
luke voight
swinging a miss a fastball with the
outside part of the plate impressive
inning for bryce he strikes out the side
here's our who grounded out second and
first his first time up
one is it second and third and two down
in the fifth tying run 90 feet away
cole the deal 2-1
hits a ground ball wide a third grabbed
by
geo he throws to first to end the inning
over boston no runs two hits two left
and here is
mike talkman a left-hand hitter
loop to left field long run for verdugo
it's gonna dunk in for base hit
torres scores easily
and talkman picks up an rbi double it's
3-1 yanks
here's gary sanchez and he has a run
over at second for talkman his fourth
rbi
deep to left center field there it goes
see ya oh
what a shot
by gary sanchez a two-run home run five
one yankees
the sanchino it's a two-run bomb to deep
left-center field
oh that gary is scary
christian vasquez with two outs and the
base is empty oh and two
um on vasquez two outs no one on in the
seventh pitch
half swing and a slider struck him out
if that is the last pitch that cole
throws if
that's his eighth strikeout so his
his line would be seven innings one run
four hits eight strikeouts he's great he
really is great three up and three down
at the end of six and a half five one
yanks
here's mike talkman
he's one for three he hit a little fly
ball double down the left alarm then
knocked in a run
lines one toward left center field there
is a base hit
scoring as herschela gleber holds it
second it's a base hit and an rbi from
mike talkman and the yankees have a 6-1
lead here's clint frazier he's over for
three on the night
hit on the ground fair over third down
the left field line rolling to the left
field corner extra base hit
torres scores tuckman scores frasier due
second with a double a two-run double
for clint frazier
and the yankees now take an 8-1 lead
frazier this is probably the knockout
punch no doubt about it another two runs
and a big hit for him huh
now here's gardner yankees have blown it
open they have an 8-1 lead
here's cubby's 1-1
and a ground ball toward the middle
and the third first in time
from our own so the bases are loaded
with nobody out and here's verdugo
and the pitch is swung on grounded
toward the middle could be two lemay you
to the short stop taurus the first safe
he beat it
and a run scores
and here's devers who's fly to center
grounded out three to one and fly to
right
hard hit and a base hit into right
jackie bradley will be trotting in to
score and the red sox are on the board
again for do go into second
give devers his fifth run bat at end
so two down for bogarts who's grounded
out 5-3 and fanned twice how do we know
strike away from getting out of the
inning deals 02 struck him out swinging
slider away
so autobino comes on and strikes out two
men in a row
now here's aaron hicks with chew on and
no one out the pitch the hicks
swinging a drive to right field hit well
toward the gap pilar on the go and he
makes a backhand running catch
just in front of the warning track
and the yankees have them loaded up with
chew out here's mike chalkman who has
doubled and singled and knocked in two
and the payoff
swung on a line to left center field has
a base hit lemay who scores voigt scores
on to third is urshela and taking second
when the throw goes awry
is talkman it's a two-run base hit for
talkman the yankees have a 10-3 lead or
shell up and third talking at second
gary sanchez the hitter
walden ready for another 2-2 here it is
and he swings and fists a fly ball to
left field toward the line verdugo back
in front of the track makes the catch to
retire the side here's jackie now
jackie is fly to right double up the gap
and left center and walked
moreland will be running three balls two
strikes two outs the pitch struck him
out swinging ball game over yankees win
the
yankees win